في السودان ، زعمت جماعة شبه عسكرية أنها
تسيطر الآن على
القصر الرئاسي والمطار في العاصمة
الخرطوم ، حيث اندلعت التوترات بين تلك
القوات والجيش وتحولت إلى
عنف عنيف بنيران كثيفة ، ووردت
أنباء عن معارك حول القصر ومقر
قيادة الجيش السفير الأمريكي في الخرطوم.
قال السودان إنه يحمي مكانه وسط
الاشتباكات التي كان الجيش مسؤولاً
عن السودان منذ انقلاب عام 2021 الذي
أنهى تقاسم السلطة الذي تم ترتيبه سابقًا
بدلاً من الإطاحة
بالرئيس السابق لفترة طويلة ،
ولنتحدث مؤخرًا عن لاري من سي إن إن.  madowo
إذن لاري ، ما الذي نعرفه أكثر عن
كل الظروف والوضع
الأجنبي الآن ،
هذا صراع بين
القوات المسلحة السودانية والمجموعة شبه العسكرية القوية جدًا
وقوات الدعم السريع التي يقودها أقوى اثنين من
الرجال العسكريين في السودان  إنها فقط
بعد الخامسة مساءً في السودان وشاهدنا
يومًا كاملاً من إطلاق النار الكثيف
والدخان المتصاعد من بعض المباني التي
تم الإبلاغ عن قتال حول مقر الجيش
وكذلك تلفزيون قصر الرئاسة الحكومي ، وهناك
مباريات ذهابًا وإيابًا وإلقاء اللوم بين
قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش حول من قام بالهجوم أولاً ، لكن
هذه التوترات كانت تتصاعد خلال
الأسبوعين الماضيين وخاصة
هذا الأسبوع وكان هذا سيحدث دائمًا
في هذا الموقف
الصعب حقًا هذا الترتيب الصعب في محاولة
لمحاولة إعادة السودان.  إلى
الحكم المدني منذ انقلاب أكتوبر 2021 الذي
ذكرته أن السودان يحكمه ما
يسمى بمجلس السيادة ، ورئيس
مجلس السيادة اللواء البرهان
هو أيضًا القائد الفعلي
للجيش والبلاد ، لكن الرجل
الثاني هو الفريق.  هميتي وهو
المسؤول عن
قوات الدعم السريع المدعومة من روسيا وأن مركز
هذا الصراع يدور حول من
سيكون مسؤولاً عن
قوة عسكرية مشتركة إذا حدث ذلك ،
فهذه نقطة شائكة في أنني عدت إلى
الحكم المدني  وأريد أن أريكم
بعض السياق المهم هنا من
وزير الخارجية الأمريكية أنتوني بلينكين
توصلت الأحزاب الرئيسية في أه بالرسوم المتحركة قبل بضعة أسابيع إلى
اتفاق إطار مهم للغاية حول كيفية المضي قدمًا في
الانتقال إلى حكومة مدنية
وكان هناك تقدم حقيقي في محاولة
ذلك  المضي قدمًا ولكن
أعتقد أن هناك فرصة حقيقية للمضي
قدمًا في إطار القراءة ، وهذا
بالتأكيد ما ندعمه
بشدة ، إنه
وضع هش ،
وتقول الولايات المتحدة إنه لا توجد خطط فورية
في هذا الوقت لإخلاء الولايات المتحدة.
العديد من المواطنين بما في ذلك المملكة المتحدة والولايات المتحدة وآخرون
يخبرون المواطنين في البلاد
بالبقاء في مكانهم. أريد أن أقرأ هذا
البيان منك أيضًا من
الاتحاد الأفريقي الذي يعد
صوتًا إقليميًا مهمًا هنا يقول إنه
يناشد الأطراف المسلحة
القوات وقوات الدعم السريع على
وجه الخصوص لوقف تدمير البلاد على الفور
وترويع سكانها وسفك
الدماء خلال الأيام العشرة الأخيرة من
شهر رمضان ، لذلك لا توجد حتى الآن أي فكرة عن إلى أين
يتجه هذا ، ولكن الكثير من الناس
قلقون فريد من أنه يمكن أن يكون.  العودة
إلى الحرب الأهلية